well what I'm worried about also in this
age of social media I've noticed as a
teacher in the classroom that the young
people are so used to communicating now
by cell phone okay by iPhone that's
they're losing body language and facial
expressions okay which i think is going
to compound the problem with with these
dating encounters okay because the
ability to read the the human face into
into to read little tiny inflections of
emotion well I think my generation got
that from looking at great foreign films
with her with their long takes okay so
you have John Merrow and Catherine
Deneuve's okay in like in potential
romantic encounters and you could you
see the tiniest little little
inflections that that signal
communication or sexual readiness or
irony or skepticism or distance or
whatever okay but the inability to read
the other people's intentions okay that
I think this is going to be a disaster
but I just noticed that how year by year
okay the students are becoming much more
flat effect
okay and they themselves complain that
they'll sit in the same room with
someone and be texting to each other
okay
yeah well there's a there's a piece of
evidence to that supports that to some
degree so women with brothers are less
likely to get raped and the reason for
that is that they've learned that
nonverbal language deeply right and they
can they can they can spot that I have
noticed okay
in my into my career okay that that
women who have many brothers they are
very good okay as administrators and as
businesspeople okay all right because
they don't take men seriously okay they
regard they saw their brothers they
think their brothers are jokes okay but
they know how to control men okay while
it while they still like men okay they
admire men right so like this is
something that I have seen you know
repeatedly yeah well so that would be
also reflective yeah the problem of
fewer and fewer siblings yes that's
right okay yeah yeah I've noticed in
publishing okay there's this that the
the women who have this is just the job
of publicists okay and rise to the top
as manager of publicity okay their
ability to take charge of men
and and and their humor in men they like
that in the end they have great
relationships with men okay because they
don't have the sense of resentment and
worry and anxiety in us and so they
don't see men as aggressors okay right
and I think that's another thing too is
that as feminism you know moved into its
present system of ideology okay
it has tended to a denigrate motherhood
okay as a lesser order of human
experience and and to enshrine of course
abortion now I am a hundred percent of
abortion rights you know I blocked a
Planned Parenthood for years until I
finally rejected it as a branch of the
Democratic Party my own party and so on
but but as motherhood became excluded as
as feminism became obsessed okay with
thee with with the worth of professional
woman okay I feel that the lessons of
that mother's learn have been lost okay
yeah to to feminism and which is okay
that if they if they're the mothers who
bear boy children okay understand the
fragility of men the fragility of boys
they understand it they don't they don't
see them men and boys and men as a
menace they understand that the greater
strength of women okay so this is this
tenderness
you know and connectedness between the
between the mother and the boy child
okay when motherhood is part of the
experience okay of of women who are
discussing gender so what we have today
is that this does gender ideology has
risen up on campuses where we're all
none of the none of the girls know the
students are married none of them have
had children okay and you have you have
women some of whom have had children but
a lot of they're lesbians or like or
like or you or like professional women
and so on so this this the whole
tenderness and forgiving forgiving this
okay and encouragement that women do to
two boys okay their fragility they don't
understand this hypersensitivity of boys
is not understood okay instead but boys
are seen as somehow now a more
privileged okay and somehow you know in
their their their energy level is
interpreted as aggression okay potential
violence and so on
okay right so I think that that that
what we would do the better okay if we
would have I have proposed okay that
colleges should allow at the moment a
woman is and
is entered okay she has interested at
college for life okay and that she that
she should be free to leave okay to have
babies when she when her body wants that
babies when it's healthy to have them
okay and then return haven't had the
occasional course so can build up
credits and fathers I mean you might be
able to do it as well and so on to get
married women women with children into
the classroom the moment that happens it
has happened after World War two okay
we've had a lot of Amit married and guys
in the classroom okay and so I'm not yet
that many women the experience of a
married person with a family okay
talking about gender but most of the
gender stuff would be laughed out of the
room okay if you had a real mother in
there who had experienced near
childbirth and head rate and it was
raising boys and so on well I think
that's that's also a you know something
that has led to this this this
incredible art you know artificiality
and an hysteria okay feminist rhetoric
good